últimamente hemos dedicado en visual
política varios vídeos a desgranar
compromisos y promesas de donald trump
es normal al fin y al cabo a partir del
20 de enero de 2017
trump es ya presidente de eeuu pues bien
en este vídeo vamos a tratar de analizar
algunas de sus apuestas en seguridad
nacional en concreto aquellas referentes
a la estrategia nuclear
[Música]
y lo hacemos porque en diciembre de 2016
saltó el escándalo cuando trump la
anunció vía twitter tal cual amigos para
saber qué se le pasa atrás por la cabeza
basta con estar atentos por muy
increíble que parezca a su cuenta de
twitter prácticamente podemos decir que
twitter es a trump lo que la m60 es a
rango o la cual 45 a billy el niño a
través de esta red
lo mismo le aconseja a israel pasar de
obama y de la onu que tacha de ser un
tipo sin talento al mismísimo editor de
la revista 'vanity fair' no importa lo
que ocurra si donald se levanta enfadado
se le atraganta el desayuno o de repente
quiere cambiar la política mundial nos
enteraremos siempre por twitter y no os
penséis que lo hacen de una forma serena
de hecho en el tramo final de la campaña
electoral sus asesores le quitaron
literalmente la cuenta pero no nos
desviemos el pasado 22 de diciembre de
trump anunció lo siguiente en twitter y
se armó la marimorena presidente electo
donald trump reaccionó por twitter y
dijo que eeuu debe fortalecer y ampliar
su capacidad nuclear hasta que el mundo
entre
sobre las consecuencias de usar armas
nucleares
pero esto qué significa porque si lo que
quiere decir es que trump apuesta por
actualizar y poner al día las
capacidades nucleares de eeuu pues
tampoco parece que haya noticia verdad
de hecho esto es lo que se apresuró a
decir su equipo de prensa para explicar
este tuit su equipo declaró después que
se refería a modernizar el arsenal no
ampliar al fin y al cabo casi nadie
cuestiona que el concepto de destrucción
mutua asegurada que surgió con las armas
nucleares fue una garantía de paz
durante la guerra fría e impidió a las
grandes potencias hacer lo que habían
hecho siempre pegados unos a otros pero
esperad un momento porque no no es eso
lo que donald trump tenía dentro de su
cabeza por supuesto no
ni 24 horas en dejar clara su postura en
su primera entrevista a la mañana
siguiente en el programa morning joe de
la msn bc trump soltó esta perla el
presidente electo de eeuu ha dicho que
hay que dejar que haya una carrera
armamentística en una declaración
telefónica fuera de antena al programa
morning joe de la cadena msn bc si así
es lo que donald trump estaba anunciando
era ni más ni menos su intención de
desencadenar una guerra armamentística y
todo con un tuit apuesto a que en ese
momento tanto sus asesores como la gente
del pentágono y de la secretaria de
estado se llevaron las manos a la cabeza
ahora comprenderéis porque en la campaña
le quitaron el twitter y ante semejante
declaración de intenciones la pregunta
no puede ser otra tiene sentido esta
afirmación es una apuesta vital y
necesaria o es que acaso como buen
populista trump sólo busca reavivar un
temor social para poder aprovecharse de
él
vamos a verlo
[Música]
la amenaza nuclear
estos son los nueve países que a día de
hoy se conoce que tienen armas nucleares
eeuu rusia china francia reino unido- la
india pakistán israel y el recién
llegado al club corea del norte claro
que no todos tienen los mismos arsenales
y las mismas capacidades tan solo rusia
y eeuu acaparan la inmensa mayor parte
de las ojivas nucleares nueve de cada
diez bombas pertenecen a estos dos
países
y os preguntaréis cuál es la amenaza
real para eeuu caso a caso
primero reino unido francia e israel no
suponen riesgo alguno son países amigos
segundo la india y pakistán no tienen
capacidad de atacar a los eeuu
de hecho su mayor riesgo especialmente
en el caso de pakistán es que algún
grupo terrorista se hiciese con el
control de alguna ojiva o de material
para fabricar bombas sucias para emplear
en atentados y desde luego este riesgo
no se combate con más misiles balísticos
en tercer lugar corea del norte se
calcula que tiene menos de 10 bombas
desarrolladas y se duda siquiera que sea
capaz de lanzar alguna en un misil
intercontinental
aún así las capacidades son tan
diferentes que en caso de que este país
pudiera y quisiera utilizar su
rudimentario arsenal en eeuu podría
destruirlo en cuestión de minutos
en cuarto lugar china el gran enemigo de
trump
bueno pues a pesar de todo lo que este
país está gastando se calcula que podría
llegar a contar con 100 cabezas
nucleares en misiles balísticos
intercontinentales dentro de 10 años un
número que en ningún caso les permitiría
impedir la represalia de las casi 1.500
cabezas nucleares que eeuu podría
utilizar en apenas unas horas y por
último rusia el gran rival de eeuu en el
terreno nuclear en este caso la
destrucción mutua está asegurada y más
ojivas no cambiarían para nada el
escenario además pese a que muchos de
los que nos veis nunca nos lo
reconoceréis no conviene olvidar la
enorme superioridad que eeuu tiene en la
guerra convencional desde la marina
hasta
pasando por la capacidad de desembarco
los ataques de precisión y por supuesto
la pasta las fuerzas armadas
estadounidenses son con diferencia las
más poderosas del planeta a mucha
distancia de esos adversarios sólo eeuu
concentra un tercio de todo el gasto
militar del mundo y otro tercio lo hace
en países que son aliados y socios
el programa está a finales de la década
de los 60 quedó clara la capacidad de
destrucción mutua entre estados unidos y
la unión soviética y la imposibilidad
así de ganar una guerra nuclear en aquel
momento la potencia norteamericana como
vais a ver en el siguiente gráfico
comenzó a reducir los arsenales y trató
de llegar a acuerdos con la unión
soviética para limitar el número de
cabezas nucleares listas para el ataque
esta estrategia han reducido en un 80
por ciento el número de armas nucleares
desplegadas desde 1989 precisamente el
último acuerdo conocido como start 3 lo
firmó obama hace relativamente poco en
2010 el acuerdo limita a 1.550 las
cabezas nucleares que ambos países
pueden tener desplegadas y limita
también los sistemas de lanzamiento en
submarinos bombarderos y misiles
intercontinentales es decir incrementar
el arsenal nuclear como defiende trump
supondría romper ni más ni menos que uno
de los acuerdos más importantes de la
historia de la humanidad y todo por
twitter
el resultado sería que estados unidos y
rusia- acumularían más cabezas nucleares
sin ganar nada en seguridad vamos como
diría fonseca menuda y de acá es tan
absurdo que en 2013 el pentágono
concluyó que eeuu podría tener un tercio
menos de armas nucleares que rusia sin
que se viese afectada la seguridad
nacional pero trump quiere más y aquí no
acaba la cosa la tríada nuclear de eeuu
una de las críticas más recurrentes de
trump es que las capacidades nucleares
están viejas y obsoletas por ello no se
cansa de decir que hay que lanzar un
mega plan para modernizarlas y poner
nuevos sistemas sobre la mesa sólo hay
un problema amigos de visual político
obama ya lo ha hecho si la
administración obama ha concedido
contratos para desarrollar nuevos
bombarderos submarinos misiles y ojivas
con los que modernizar el equipamiento
de eeuu y mejorar así su capacidad de
ataque nuclear por tierra
y aire lo que se conoce como la tríada
nuclear
el presupuesto es ojo descomunal más de
800 mil millones de dólares en las
próximas décadas de los cuales 350.000
se habrán gastado ya dentro de 8 años
de hecho hace muy poco el pentágono
presentó por ejemplo el nuevo super
bombardero nuclear de 21 ryder que será
tremendamente sigiloso y caro cada
unidad costará 550 millones sin contar
el presupuesto de desarrollo la pregunta
que muchos hacen hoy en washington es si
eeuu debe hacer frente a semejante gasto
puede que por todo esto james mattis
alias perro loco el general retirado que
trump ha escogido como secretario de
defensa de fin e incluso que el programa
nuclear tenga que reducirse es llamativo
que en algo tan importante como la
estrategia nuclear
trump tenga tan poco en cuenta a la
persona que has cogido para dirigir a
las fuerzas armadas y es que parece de
cajón pensar que la política de defensa
amigos no puede conducirse por twitter
bueno
y tú qué piensas de eeuu romper con la
política de los últimos 30 años y
lanzarse a una carrera armamentística
contradice todo esto los mensajes de
trump en campaña por cierto si quieres
conocer la controvertida apuesta
comercial de trump puedes ver este vídeo
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]